as great of a state California is why
did California lose nearly 700 000
people the last three four years and on
top of that 352 businesses left
California 11 of them in the fortune
1000 61 of the businesses over 100
employees then we we dug up some numbers
you were like what side is California
voting we noticed the last seven
presidential elections they voted blue
but prior to that six consecutive
presidential election California voted
read that six in a row so then we broke
it down by counties we went and looked
at different counties LA County San
Diego County Orange County Riverside
County San Bernardino County to see if
all of these states are blue are they on
the left one of the counties you're not
going to believe which county this is 19
out of the last 22 presidential
elections since 1936 they voted rent
they voted Republican what how's that
possible then you break it down and you
you see that cars they're saying don't
lock up the car anymore leave the
windows down because they're breaking
into the window if they're going to
steal it let them steal it you know
people are saying don't drive to work
because you may get robbed there's drugs
on the streets in the state of you know
in San Francisco with regulation we
looked at ranking for the best small
business we looked at so many different
data we're going to go and look into
right now but there's a reason why
people are leaving California this is
not accidental we're going to get into
it today
foreign
give it a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel California beautiful state
incredible weather lots of great things
to do there but they're getting their
asses handed to them first of all I'm
going to go into politics here in a
minute but let me first kind of give you
where they rank business-wise so here's
an article from Chief executive.net they
rank the best and worst states for
business if you look at the list based
on different golf scores they have at
the top in 2023 it's Texas then Florida
Tennessee North Carolina Arizona Indiana
Georgia South Carolina then Nevada Utah
at the bottom top 50 states you ready
number 50 California 49 New York then
Illinois Jersey Oregon Washington
Massachusetts Hawaii Connecticut Alaska
Minnesota Newsom always brags about
where his GDP is a look at us where the
fourth or the fifth biggest economy in
the world there's a reason why we make
so much revenues that could be true but
the way to look at it is the following
Newsome became a governor what three
four years ago after he took over Jerry
Brown I believe so imagine a company you
built Steve Jobs builds the company then
it's Tim cookman let's just say Okay so
different seals come in and this company
is now a three trillion dollar company
and then you show up your name is Newsom
and all of a sudden the company loses
700 000 customers and the top line
revenue drops a little bit and you're at
the bottom of the list for companies to
work for that doesn't mean you're not a
big company you could still be a
multi-trillionado company but you've
hurt the company so Newsom as a CEO has
destroyed that state the last few years
purely Based on data so let's look at
some areas on what caused this thing to
happen so look I've been in the
financial industry since 9 11 the day
before 9 11 and I've owned stocks bonds
mutual funds real estate crypto gold you
name it I've owned it but the one thing
that's very important part of my
portfolio all these years is gold I love
having a percentage of my net worth in
gold that I have access to in case of
many different things a few facts you
need to know about gold number one the
gold market cap is 11.8 trillion dollars
since 2000 the compound annual growth
rate for gold old has been 9.24 percent
and during times of high inflation three
percent plus has been 15.35 percent now
those are just some numbers for you but
there's some other benefits to add gold
to your portfolio number one hedge
against inflation number two results
showed recently that 93 of central banks
are working on a cbdc so this means what
that could be a manipulated currency
that they own if you own gold it's a
non-duplicatable asset you're now
hedging against cbdc taking place number
three a potential cyber threat if it
happens you don't have access to your
money you don't have access to your
account where you have access to your
hard physical gold number four is
anonymous no one knows you have that
gold and last but not least
diversification that's why we chose to
work with our new sponsor American
Hartford gold if you have retirement
funds that you cannot afford to lose
American Hartford gold will ship
physical gold or silver directly to your
door also if you have retirement funds
that you can't afford to lose now is the
time to call American Heart for gold a
precious metal dealer you can trust they
have the finest products amazing
customer service and a buyback
commitment they've earned a five-star
rating from thousands of reviews and an
A plus from the Better Business Bureau
tell them I sent you and they'll send
you up to five thousand dollars worth of
free silver on your first order so click
on the link in the description or call
866-939-6984 again
866-939-6984 on this list here of
regulations which states have the most
regulated states in America by number of
restrictions 2022. guess what state is
at the top with the most regulations for
businesses you ready California 403
000 number two is New York 298 three is
Jersey 286 Illinois Ford 279 and it is
Texas 273 but California is an overly
regulated State and by the way when you
look at the top industries most
regulated in California ready Number One
Insurance what industry think I'm a part
of the last 20 something years Insurance
then it's petroleum then it's core
products and Manufacturing and in its
paper manufacturing the these industries
are heavily regulated you want to know
what the least regulated Industries are
let me tell you the least regulated
Industries social assistance surprising
like welfare entitlement programs number
two Waste Management then it's
remediation and Educational Services low
regulation the other guys heavily
regulated okay Pat we get your point
very much a regulated staple what's
what's the big deal with that what else
can you tell us outside of that no
problem let me tell you what happened to
you with a couple companies you ever
heard of Geico you know that gecko that
walks around and it does these funny
commercials and what gecko decided to do
they just shut down their office in
California not one they just closed all
their offices we don't want to do
business in California what do you mean
we're out we're leaving California Geico
left California yes who else Progressive
stopped advertising in California State
Farm is no longer taking calls for
quotes in California you need to go to
an office Insurance professionals from
California say most companies are not
extremely reluctant to underwrite new
policies specifically on the auto
insurance Side California has a
government-controlled insurance system
that distorts the free market so now
we've talked a few different things here
but you may say Pat I still get it but
you know I still think it's the greatest
you know place to be I'm gonna give you
another data here the last three years
2019 21 2020 21 22. okay the top 10
highest tax states in America California
New York Illinois top 10 highest tax
states in America lost
391 billion dollars of AGI that's
adjusted gross income they lost 391. you
want to know what the crazy status here
the bottom 10 states like Florida Texas
Tennessee guess what they picked up in
those three years you ready guess the
number you're going to get it right the
same exact amount let me say this again
the top 10 highest tax states lost 391
of AGI the bottom 10 gained 391 billion
in adhdi what does that tell you these
guys simply took their block of business
and they went here that's kind of like
you working at Morgan Stanley Deanwood
you got a billion dollars of money under
management you took your billion and
your hundred clients and you went where
Goldman Sachs that's what happened they
left the top 10 states America is saying
we don't want to be in states with high
regulation and high taxes we're going to
go elsewhere and guess what Florida
Texas Tennessee and other places said
come on down we'll take you Texas took
Rogan Texas took musk Texas took Toyota
Florida took a bunch of them Tennessee
took a bunch of them no problem and
California kept saying it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
we're okay we're California we're New
York we're just and this keeps happening
over and over and over again so let me
give you some specific stats here you
know when I said earlier they lost over
61 companies with over 100 employees you
know those companies that we said 61
companies with 100 plus employees where
did they go 27 of them you know where
they went Texas 44 Arizona got eight
percent of them then Colorado then
Carolina then Florida then Tennessee
they went from here all the way down to
Florida easy part is what to just go to
Texas which they did 27 of the 61 with
100 plus employees move their companies
to Texas all right so let's go a little
bit deeper California did something it's
been it's been happening for a while
they've been trying to do this the whole
thing with Uber laws well these are
independent contractors but we should
treat them like employees Uber should
treat them as full-time agents we try to
do this with some salespeople it's
called the assembly Bill five
legislation was signed into a law by
Governor Newsom in September of 2019
requiring companies that hire
independent contracts to reclassify them
as employees can you imagine Uber driver
drives five hours a week they want them
to be an employee getting benefits from
a company like uber Uber can't afford to
do this so these regulations when they
did guess who started complaining the
independent contractors like don't do
this I want my job I don't want Uber to
leave the state I don't want these
insurance companies to leave the state I
want to keep selling as a part-time
individual working for Uber or Lyft so
California's law got the independent
contractors who vote Democrats to say
listen leave this one alone I like
working 10 hours a week for Uber I don't
want them to leave the state so they
kind of backed off and they're like whoa
we're losing our own people that don't
don't like this idea what about if we
kind of create this ABC workers free
from control and direction in the
performance of services and workers
performing work outside of the usual
course by the business of the hiring
company and the workers customarily
engaged in an independently established
trade occupational business they kind of
are like trying to say well we're
controlling it but we're not because
these people don't like it leave them
alone they want to be kind of left alone
as an independent contractor that's one
policy that made businesses to say if
you're doing it now odds are you're
eventually going to find a way to
enforce this I better leave now before
you do something with it you ready for
next one the trucking industry I got a
lot of friends in California and
trucking industry ready for what they
just announced effective January 1st
2024 any trucks registered on or after
January 1st 2024 must be zero emissions
zero emissions that's in four months
California's truck ban requires that
about 55 percent of delivery Vans at
small trucks 75 percent of buses and
larger trucks and 40 percent of tractor
trailers and other big rigs be fully
electric by 20 35 by 2045 gas and diesel
trucks will be outright banned from
being sold together
absolutely banned can you imagine like
the state says absolutely banned in the
state of California now you may say well
Pat that's a good idea climate change
I'm in La I see how dark it is this is a
good thing the sky is dark the clouds
are dark isn't this a good thing are you
anti-making the climate cleaner uh do
you know what it takes to build electric
cars and how much of the climate it
hurts to build have you looked at what
they do to the people that you are
against them working them like
sweatshops have you looked into that
stuff so that's already a lot of work to
force for us to go in this directions
going to be very problematic in the
state of California but fine fine no
problem let's go to the next one gas
powered tool ban ab1346 will require the
state to adopt regulations around these
gas powered tools by July 1st of 2022
and ban their sale by the start date of
2024. moving forward you can't buy a gas
powered tool bandage 2024 how crazy is
that that's California for you next one
as well so I had a guy that came to me
were Consulting for this client that
runs 10 restaurants Nationwide he does
around 40 million a year and he's asking
what do I do in the state of California
so let me tell you what they're doing to
restaurant owners and restaurant workers
that's costing these guys a lot of money
so fun fact California will establish a
10-member fast food sector Council
tasked with establish some standards on
minimum wages maximum working hours
training and other working conditions
applicable to Industry workers the
council would raise the minimum wage to
22 bucks an hour in 2023 and up to three
and a half percent annually after that
special Authority specifically
authorizes fast food restaurant workers
to bring causes of action for discharge
discrimination or retaliation for
exercising rights established by the
fast Recovery Act so guess what that
does if you're running a fast food
business you're like oh my God what do I
do okay so if I pay them 22 bucks an
hour that means that going from a
minimum wage of 720 or maybe 10 bucks an
hour to now 22 so whatever I was
charging for the food a burger is going
to go from two dollars to four dollars
which I have to pass that crossed over
to customers that they got to pay in
California or someone's going to say
honestly it's just not worth me doing
business in California do people realize
what the margins are in restaurants
three four five percent these guys are
not making a lot of money and Running a
Restaurant you know how hard it is to
run a restaurant have you ever had a
family run restaurant in your like in
your family you ever worked there how
annoying and hard that job is you want
to make it harder for them they're going
to leave your state is what they're
going to do but no problem you may say
Pat not a big deal we'll tolerate that
great let's look at some other things
highest tax rates individual income by
state guess who's the highest number one
13.3 percent but you may say Pat I'm I
don't have a problem paying the 13-3
because the weather is perfect you're
great how high are the sales taxes in
your state California top 10 is number
eight at eight point eight two how about
corporate income tax California top six
or seven at eight point eight four
percent how about electricity bill when
you look at five states you ready Look
at California where they're ranked look
at the color okay if you look at the top
navy blue is the lowest and it goes to
blue yellow orange red look at red hot
red California electricity bill what if
we look at median home values Look at
California navy blue 522
000 the only ones ahead of California
more expensive is Hawaii 638 and you got
DC at 606. how about taxes on gasoline
where's California you're at what do you
think California is so competitive they
decided to take number one on this list
here per gallon you know how much they
charge for Tax Ready
65.1 cents it's the highest in America
the lowest is Alaska by choice it's only
8.95 yet California is six and a half
times higher so this is all economy you
may say Pat I don't care about economy
stuff I want socially you know I just
want to raise my kids in a place that
I'm comfortable with no problem let's
talk about social issues Senate Bill 107
September of 2022 Newsom signed this
into law blocking states with anti-trans
laws from Prosecuting families who seek
gender or firming care in California
making it the first trans Sanctuary
state if you want to be part of the
first trans Sanctuary state California
is a perfect home for you next assembly
Bill 5 the safe and supportive School
act would mandate that teachers and
credentialed staff who serve Public
School pupils in grades 7 through 12
take an online training course in lgbtq
cultural competency again if that's
important to you California is a perfect
home for you and by the way just so you
know I have a bunch of others that I can
read to you a bunch of other bills that
if you want to entertain yourself you
can find them everywhere I'm not going
to go through all this stuff I think you
get the point but how do we get here
because like I said to you earlier one
County okay one of the top five biggest
counties in California the last 22
presidential election 19 times they
voted Republican in California what in
California so and in the last seven
elections they've all voted for
Democrats but prior to that sixth
straight California voted red Republican
how do we get here so if you look at
this chart here's what you'll notice
okay Democrats currently hold a 60 to 18
super majority in the ADC California
State Assembly and it's been majority
like that since about 1996 but if you
look at this chart for from 92 to 2022
look how 1994 it was once read in 1994
Pete Wilson ran the Save Our State
initiative which got Republicans to lose
a ton of the Democrats why because
nearly 40 percent of Californians are
Hispanic and they sat there and said
what is this guy doing 40 percent of the
population is US Reds Republicans are
against us we can't vote for something
like this I was in high school the
biggest conversation in high school was
inis is going to come get you Inez is
going to come get you that's around the
same time I was in high school so Pete
Wilson had a reputation of treating
Hispanics and illegal immigrants harshly
he put forward prop 187 which denied all
public services to illegal immigrants
and forced all state employees to
immediately report illegal immigrants to
the immigration and naturalization
service for deportation immigration
Naturalization Service ins for
deportation and California having won
the largest Hispanic population in
America 40 I think Texas at 47 percent
they Associated Republicans with being
anti-hispanic not for them so they said
were voting on the other side okay so
this leads me to the top five counties
in the state of California number one
being the LA County 9.7 million then in
San Diego Then Orange County then
Riverside then San Bernardino which of
these counties do you think 19 out of 22
last elections voted on the red I want
you to guess let's go through it here we
go first one L.A County when you look at
LA County notice what you see on the
left it shows all the years 1936 all the
way all the way down to 2016. I have the
2020 results as well I'll give it to you
but out of if you notice all the check
marks are blue you see a couple red six
Reds over there which means in LA county
last 22 elections six times has been
read 16 times has been blue Salt Lake
County goes to the Democrats now next
one second largest San Diego County if
you look at San Diego County for the
last 22 14 out of 22 went Red by the way
if you look at the consecutive red there
was a point where 14 out of 15.
presidential elections San Diego voted
on the right San Diego and for the last
four it's been in on the blue okay next
one ready Orange County 19 out of 22 red
19 out of 22 red there's a lot of great
pockets in Orange County Manhattan Beach
Newport some areas you can go to where
there's a lot of people that are on that
side so OC for some of you that are
wondering about California thinking
about staying there you may want to go
find a place in OC the next one
Riverside County which was kind of
surprising did you know 15 out of 22
elections they voted red Riverside
County 15 out of 22. yep that's what
they did 15 out of 22 voted red and last
but not least San Bernardino 12 out of
the last 22 which means over 50 so there
are counties in California who are
sitting there saying listen man we are
not for what these guys are doing we are
fully against it and those counties if
you're somebody that's watching and
saying have no desire to leave
California I totally get it if you're
not figure right away to make some
change because the current policies are
destroying your state if you're watching
this thing I don't think it's going to
change the next 10 years and I got a kid
that's six years old right now by the
time it changes my kid's already 16
years old they can and talk to him I
wouldn't take the risk if I were you I
would start door knocking talking to my
husband or my wife and saying hey let's
look at Tennessee let's go to Texas I
would spend the next four weekends going
to a different state each weekend go to
Texas go to Tennessee Nashville go to
Florida go to Nevada go to these
different markets next eight weekends
next six weekends and I say babe we have
family here we're gonna go to Houston
we're going to go to Dallas we're going
to go to Miami we're going to go to
Jackson we're going to go to Nashville
pick and choose but if you're staying do
your fight if you're leaving start
looking at this why because bad policies
have consequences and California is so
arrogant about it that they don't think
anyone's going to do anything because
they don't believe you have the guts and
the courage to leave they think they
have you locked in and you're afraid to
leave that's what they think about you
California they don't think you have the
courage to leave there's a word for
people like that Newsome thinks you're
that just so you know I don't mean to
offend you I'm just telling you that's
how they're playing with you they say I
dare you go ahead make a move and most
of you are not okay so either get
involved in politics either move to a
better County either do something about
it or go to a different state especially
if you have young kids right now because
it doesn't look like this thing's going
to change anytime soon if you got value
out of this video give it a thumbs up
and subscribe to the channel and if you
enjoyed this video there's another video
we did on DC wait till you see what
they're doing in DC it's absolutely
crazy if you've not seen it click here
to watch it take everybody bye bye
foreign